the birthday paradox refers to the
likelihood of two people within a random
group sharing the same birthday given
the fact that there are 366 possible
birthdays including February 29th step
it doesn't seem all that likely but in a
room of 23 people there's actually more
than a 50% chance that two of those
people share the same birthday if that
seems high consider this in a group of
23 people there are actually 253
possible chances for a match so might
not make sense to your brain but that
doesn't really matter because you know
man so we're out here on the street to
put the birthday paradox to the test by
the time we hit 23 people there's a
fifty point seven percent chance that
two of them will have the same birthday
are we going to be that lucky I don't
know let's find out all right so here's
our first person your name is Bob Bob
when's your birthday January 30th 1959
now since you're the first person
there's no chance of you winning this
that's okay
when's your birthday Casey November 30th
boomer November 26 boomer October 15 no
much still don't have a match but it's
pretty good we're getting there hello
there sir what's your name
Odin mm-hmm Odin when's your birthday
June 21st
whew September 26 Norma April 15th
oh yeah boy 11 not oh man here we go
August 25th boomer January 23rd boomer
September 18th boomer rod when is your
birthday
my birthday is January 4th mmm
boomer I'm so sorry Roger well that
necklace this is goodbye
it is oh oh September 24th October 31st
May 8th mmm
none of these are matches sorry guys hi
I'm here with Jackie and Fernando
and what do we got for birthdays October
31st I think October 31st is a big
winner I think it's a winner let's
double check Jackie yes your neck it's a
winner I got a special treat for you
guys
this is the best day ever there you go
just a nice Halloween cake guys thank
you for thank you for being born so
there you have it
16 people and we found two wonderful
souls with the same birthday on
Halloween of all dates how spooky so the
birthday paradox it's a real thing